yes hello and welcome to this video on
playing dynamic brain I've got the white
pieces here what do i slave gap lady for
for a change
okay od6 don't see that too often the
Steinitz defense not not yet not exactly
a popular but probably not going to
equalize for lack but it cannot be
terrible of course I mean a black now
takes on d4 for example plays Bishop d7
good 97 Wow so so D 5 a 6 is the idea
what I wonder is what happens if I take
it only five twenty eggs Queen d8 King D
895 things like that look look strange
eight Bishop c4 an idea maybe he covers
everything okay D 5 a 6 Bishop b2 also
should be should be better for Wyatt yes
sir will night b8 and then c4 for some
kind of Kings Indian we have legs pieces
look a bit strange so D takes you five
looks
hmm cake stakes 95 King 8 air maybe
Bishop c4 98 + f6 kicking kicking me out
d5 is still blank would come back let's
do it it's it's probably not the best
move but it leads to a position type
then I know from d4 see for openings and
jam yeah I'm certainly certainly fine so
um how to do it I guess you form
yeah yeah I think h4 h4 is good
directly addressing him them like you
cannot really play h5 of this one so g3
and tending h5 immediately h5 Knight f4
mites might have been okay from
so h5 night h8 now and then f5 mixed
numbers to make sense h6 i think is not
great
which is 93 I guess so I expect them to
go f5 here opening the F file
that is surprising because I think he
should not trade the light square bishop
c6 okay
Jesus I don't know what's going on and
not really I'm not having a cold the
only thing that's a little bit annoying
is that Bishop g5 now is maybe on but
it's not it's not a huge deal okay so
[Music]
let's see if I go g4 he's never going to
play at five but Bishop g5 this is on
the cards and one letter should go
Knight f3 here actually preventing the
bishop move and still intending G form I
mean f5 is f5 is not great anyway I
guess even though for f5 then that would
be better only to it if you really place
f5 so beard okay so interesting question
is if I should play g4 and g5 first
they're probably not very interesting
question to be honest now that I think
of it
hmm okay before you can do that
she forgave 8 I'm not certain that that
really helps me all that much got
neither 5 to g5 and if I go g4 back g5
it looks a little bit it looks a little
bit loose 9 f7 I have grouped g1 now it
should be good fun right down
so g5
just keeping like as boxed in as
possible really Wow these are the kind
of decisions that should not be taken in
two seconds out okay so canceling long
get some
okay so this one and now I'm threatening
g6 and if that hits it's night on h8 is
dead
okay so g6 and you're really going to
play this position g6 takes takes I have
92 Queen h4 that's never going to hold
absolutely never okay
okay so he plays without the knight then
for the rest of the game oh okay
so if I'm not checkmated somehow on the
Queen side I'm winning this game but how
do i exactly win queen 2e6 check that is
something that would definitely put
asking some questions we should take h6
I could have played actually maybe now
it doesn't really matter
okay so he's not opening up that file on
the queenside I was thinking you would
take go okay so I'll take back okay I
don't mind the take back its deposition
is completely winning any out but I
don't think I know maybe he just maybe
click the light on h8 okay
tick 24:04 for the chicken
community 626 is a big issue and I'm
also yeah maybe Bishop takes h6 I also
might threaten but yeah not a big issue
anyway can also play an ending because
well this is the night down
you just can't rate down with rooks
traded for example I just go King to g4
f-5e 6 and so on
let's keep it simple
attending will gave three
you see is actually a winning concept
just go for it don't think about
something fancier I mean just trading
down everything into this ending wings
effortlessly so just do it
you can absolutely not do anything
okay so f form is the thing - final step
in and now um yeah it's basically down
to moving the rook from this seven to
the d8 that on a nice square
yeah yeah you cannot move ready whoop
the aid
they said night h8 was amiss click now
how the position was some Watson
Patito wanted to a chain right okay
anyway so how do i how do I win this now
as good as it looks you still have to
win it fancy way would be to the second
e6 somehow and then make make em win
with the GEEP on as this night is not
doing anything the question is is that
really is so convincing look on to e6
also would be nice just this position
with the rook on d6 it would be good
first of all I'm going to put the knight
on to f5 and then we'll be three to e6
if necessary
I might just even take on e7 then
No okay I did not think about this huh
now let's it's bad I mean I think I can
go Bishop g3 I overlooked this trick
blacks position is probably so bad it
doesn't really do much you see how it
okay now I've landed 96 but now I think
that's too much hanging I'm just
threatening to take it if you move City
seven thoughts so I'm winning material
yeah but somehow this game discontinued
okay so
I should I have to do something down in
the middle of the freakin game it's not
good maybe I can manage
how do I win here we have to put the
bishop under no there's no long diagonal
here to put it
I managed to do this quickly I really
have to go it is really totally winning
him to can I manage to do this quickly
sitting have to buy some buy something
at the door
you
you
please resign I need to get outside and
do some stuff ah thanks a lot again and
now I can go on to the analysis Borland
quickly pause this ok I'm back so let's
have a look at this game um yeah we had
the Wii and he played d6 d4
why does he say it's not like me
accepting take-backs I usually do
especially if I mean the position was I
wanted to show how that is modern
looking at tape and I mean especially it
looked like because in that Muslim and
okay so he went Knight to e7 the average
I was thinking this at first but I
couldn't quite find something great I
mean I was thinking here
but King AIDS Bishop c4 98 is actually
heard everything and if I have to just
go back after f6 that didn't really help
yeah I defy this not bad because he
basically has to play a six the only way
to save the annoyed if I go here d5 is
okay I think for black so I went to you
two and now back so I have a now see for
a position that is very typical of a
default planning like a King's Indian
old Indian something like that and now I
have gained some time I have taken two
moves b-52
we tool so I lost the temple there but
he lost to with the night back and forth
and he had said a six which is pretty
useless him oftentimes rather weakening
and the night only seven I expected g6
yes the engine suggests and then we'll
probably get something like this I mean
why should be better due to space and so
on but it's nothing nothing terrible for
like yeah ninety-six ch4 is the most
yeah sighs of movement it is one of the
engines twelve choices Bishop to e7 yeah
immediately this night therefore I did
not like so much I mean I can take and
try to win this pawn something like this
but he gets really good we shut down if
you have checked this is very good
please now I didn't like this so g3 in
order to play h5 later makes more sense
or cancels and now the night is sent to
age eight you know age six is given by
the comfier I don't like that much let's
see three is good I think
and now Bishop g4 headed as I was
surprised by that move because he does
not really want to exchange the bishops
strategically speaking
and maybe h6 as the engine indicates was
a better choice I probably yeah there
should be three I probably would have
played like this maybe at five six takes
and now 92 and why it should be better
than with this e 4 squared Bishop g4
coming but you know the engine Quincy
Aiden so think this is kind of viable
maybe it is yeah Bishop g4 I think was
not helping c6 and no Knight h4 is
stronger even than 92 okay I didn't want
to give them the opportunity to take on
h4 and this is actually me I am I can't
eat with the pawn this is the thing of
course this is very strong the open G
file will killed like him
keep castles rook g1 and over basica so
that was even stronger yeah and here he
could have played Bishop g5 but I have
f4 I think you know F hole must be good
this is and then the King goes to see -
I mean what is this okay so like 97 and
a plate Knight f3 preventing anything
like on g5 and preparing G form so he
went a 5 before I played that form it
takes
g4 pushing it back g5 gaining more space
and now c5 I was really surprised that
you played c5 because it felt like it
stops any sort of hope here with Queen
85 or 95 or so
[Music]
the position is bad however really bad
already
who ate there and now I'm threatening g6
and cannot really do much about it now
taking it doesn't work like here and
then 95 was my thought now it does
William something like this you cannot
cannot really stand yeah and after age
60 plays the piece down queen g4 was
even more powerful yeah but that's
really not important I mean now I'm
playing a piece of happened we have
multiple ways of winning the easiest to
just trade I read it in the game I think
this is all all fine technically
speaking now I I went to this F with
this ribbon thing and I didn't see
Knight xt6 really blundered this and I
shouldn't have allowed it just for
clarity sake and don't don't allow this
kind of thing I can start with this for
example turned over the fun yet we can
no sorry you can do this but and you're
playing without this piece yeah so here
you could take and in fact this did win
as well yeah that's also fairly with him
because you win you win all pawns it's
really really nice win the more at
Bishop g3 also goes
the house yeah
ths it's reasonably simple yeah the the
position really got problematic I think
once he somehow was sent to age eight
yeah I mean it really doesn't make a
good impression to get to go there even
though the engine still of things that
here after age six the position is
somewhat acceptable maybe I can improve
I wanted to go Bishop III the engine
head to the server sorry this idea in
order to play G form this is interesting
clip here and then Knight aged for
probably taking into account that here
black cannot take on h4 and in fact this
looks terrible 24 coming and so on
rook g1 looks looks like an interesting
yeah okay guys hope you enjoyed the game
thanks for watching